die schattenseiten eines youtube das
licht nach liebes licht du spielst gegen
mich hallo leute hier ist heute wieder
eure mal wanne und dieses mal gibt es
frisuren und was sie bedeuten also viel
spaß diese frisur nenne ich eine und
gewicht frauen ihre raupen tragen können
können es aus zwei gründen erstens sie
haben die haare dafür das ist wirklich
gut aussieht wenn sie die offen tragen
oder es ist den wirklich egal du hast
das goldene hufeisen und bibi und tina
sind deine besten freunde
wenn du den fischgräten zopf kannst du
sie mich zur oberliga kannst du malen
wie das farbenspiel des wildfremde erde
ist nur fremd wenn der fremde sie nicht
zweifel bedeutet entweder hast du vor
heute abend einen mann zu überraschen
oder du solltest wirklich therapeuten
aufsuchen
naja du scheinst du gesagt dass meine
frisur scheiße aussieht
ich schwöre ich denke gleich was scheiße
aussieht wenn du wie sarkozy gleich
scheiße rauskommen was willst du
ich glaube dazu muss ich nichts sagen
diese frisur heißt dein weg hat heute
nicht geklingelt deine haare wollten
nicht so wie du willst
oder du gehst zum sport ein bandana
bedeutet tupac ich denk an dich und
diese frisur heißt ich muss mir mal die
haare waschen ich hoffe euch hat das
video gefallen wenn ja dann gibt dem
daumen nach oben oder abonniert mich
hier unten und dann sehen uns das
nächste mal ganz viel lieber an euch und
seid nicht böse wenn ich eine frisur
genommen habt die ihr vielleicht trägt
und so es ist ja alles nicht so ernst
gemeint ich hoffe ihr versteht dass bis
dann schoss commerce scheiße was war es
scheiße oder was aufs maul